as of guys my name is a channel welcome
to a little update video just about a
few things that's gonna basically happen
on this channel and regarding videos and
whatnot so first of all I know I haven't
been uploading too much and that's
because I'm in the middle of semester in
university now this is very difficult to
do for subjects and keep up a pretty
good YouTube channel when um when you're
trying to basically you know do well
like in university so that's why that's
that's the reason for lack of video
there's not because I don't want to make
them it's not because I can't be
bothered or anything it's because I
literally don't have time I'm actually
basically barely finding the time to
record this right now but um what I
thought about doing was essentially
incorporating my university work into my
youtube kind of work and what I mean by
that is I'm studying I'm setting a
course which is called professional
software development and I'm actually
doing a unit this semester called game
programming okay because I want to major
than that
and essentially what I have to do for
that is you can probably guess is make a
bunch of games so and that kind of falls
into into what you guys I subscribed for
so what I thought was I could basically
kind of kill two birds with one stone
you know and basically stream myself
making those games right so I'm actually
doing a really cool project right now
because basically the way this works is
to get a distinction or higher in the
subject and you have to make a game like
a rather big game which demonstrates a
lot of different criteria and to get a
high distinction which of course is what
I'm going for
you need to both make that game and and
do a research report okay so the game
that I'm gonna be making is gonna be
tied in with my research report and
basically what I'm gonna be making is a
very small so don't don't don't go live
scale on this but very small kind of
minecraft clone okay in C++ and then I'm
gonna port it to Java the same game same
everything and compare the performance
because a lot of people seem to think
it'll be much faster in C++ but and if
it probably will be like marginally
faster but not really anything
significant but the point is I'm gonna
be doing that or
comparing all all sorts of performance
data between the two versions of that so
I imagine that a lot of you probably
want to see me make my crafts so that's
why I'm thinking that I might live
stream myself developing that now there
will be a lot of like a lot of
documentation going on with as well I've
actually started I actually started it
yesterday and you guys probably see what
it looks like right now on the screen
it's basically just a bunch of blocks
with um some kind of nice shading and
nothing really special I did start this
yesterday keep in mind and I'm making it
from scratch in SDL using OpenGL in SL -
so yeah so there's not too much to show
right now but obviously I want to
develop it keep you on weave eat that
being said if you guys are interested
please leave a comment I probably do
this anyway even if you guys are
interested I mean you guys will be all
at least most of you will be so um
that's what's gonna happen on Ellison
C++ but that's just because you know the
the you know I will be putting into Java
eventually that being said I mean that's
about all I wanted to say isn't it maybe
yeah so it is already on github by the
way all the code will be on github both
the both the original like version and
say if I was called chew and I craft by
the way because why not do I think the
code will be on github it is on
github.com 4/2 Cherno which is my github
right there's a repository called Cherno
craft or an in C++ and that is the
basically my progress so far so you guys
can follow along with that don't
contribute to that obviously don't open
issues and pull requests because um you
know I'm not actually allowed to get
people to help me with this obviously so
I'm gonna obviously not accept your you
know your alterations to this but um go
ahead and fork it and play around with
it if you like if you guys find any bugs
or something that you think is bad you
can kind of tell me on the DL on the
download but um that that's totally fine
by the way but um just keep in mind that
that whole thing it will be up there so
yeah you guys can play it on the card
and knock yourselves out licensing is
standard GPL right so just make sure you
credit me if you use it for anything but
otherwise it's free and open source that
being said the other thing I did and
some was calling me to climb
what the other thing I did was um yes so
SoundCloud right on some day i'm
actually gonna upload the already ready
to go music video of me making the music
field for the London air game because a
lot of you guys requested that and it's
literally the only part of the
development livestream that doesn't have
copyrighted music well not really
cooperating music with music I don't
have permission to because I did make
the music for that during that period of
time so it'd be like an hour and a half
long I think it's like an hour forty
long it'll be up on Sunday so I know you
guys a lot of you guys happened to be
interested in music which is great so
you guys can see me kind of make a very
rough track in an hour 40 minutes from
ideas to final production that'll be out
on Sunday and speaking of that stuff I
did make a SoundCloud account what did I
just say a SoundCloud account
specifically for this and for this I
mean like for kind of my music alright
so if you guys are interested in that it
soundcloud.com 4/2 Cherno link will be
in the description and basically I mean
that I'm just gonna dump random music
that I that I play there alright I mean
right not like you you guys want to hear
me sing like that's the play so there's
actually a that's actually a very rough
kind of cover up there right now
actually week including me singing so go
ahead and check that out but just keep
in mind you know it's it's it's just for
fun and it's it's don't expect high
quality music that I'll be dumping all
sorts of stuff there which I'm sure most
of you guys will enjoy that being said
um I'll see you guys next time and I'll
see you guys all throughout the week
live streaming alright so have a good
time like the video if you liked it and
goodbye